con el papá emérito benedicto 16 admitió
haber proporcionado información no es
falsa a una investigación alemana sobre
abusos sexuales cometido por un
sacerdote dentro de la iglesia católica
esto aconteció en la última semana
aseguró que se había asistido a una
reunión con funcionarios de la iglesia
local en 1980 cuando se desempeñaba como
arzobispo de munich para hablar sobre un
sacerdote sospechoso de pedofilia antes
de rectificar en una declaración escrita
joseph ratzinger había dicho que estaba
ausente durante esa reunión algo que
ahora atribuye a un error editorial toda
esta polémica se suscitó tras la
publicación de un informe sobre los
presuntos abusos sexuales en la
arquidiócesis alemana de múnich y que le
atribuye a benedicto 16 no haber actuado
al menos en cuatro casos conocidos y
ocurridos bajo su jerarquía vamos a
conversar sobre los escándalos dentro de
la iglesia católica y saludamos para
ello a marcial sánchez gaete doctor en
historia y experto en la iglesia
católica doctor sánchez desgracias y
cómo leer a un papá en su retiro esté
vinculado con inacción en un caso de
abuso contra menores y cometidos en la
iglesia
mira la verdad que con todos los temas
que hemos conocido en el último tiempo
abusos sexuales dentro de esta
institución
no cabía duda que en algún momento
alguno de los papás iba a estar ya
vinculado directamente y por qué digo
esto porque la crisis efectivamente
dentro de la iglesia de una crisis
sistémica y estructural como ya venimos
diciendo ya hace un tiempo es tan
profunda que efectivamente está lógico
cubrimiento llegaba a todos los ámbitos
y bueno ahora estamos dándonos cuenta
que cuando el papá el papa ratzinger
cuando el arzobispo
también cayó en lógica encubrimiento que
era una lógica da la sensación o mejor
dicho ya estamos seguros que era una
lógica y esto cuando uno dice eso es
porque hay un sistema que se empieza a
instaurar y es un sistema de una
realidad de dolor bueno cuando ya
llegamos a este punto obviamente que yo
creo que es un punto sin retorno
lamentablemente debo decirlo como
analista en el área que soy es un punto
sin retorno porque yo creo que estamos
entrando
al final de la iglesia católica conocida
cuando ya te involucras a la cabeza
máxima y tenemos arzobispos como los
obispos marx que ya viene hace un tiempo
diciendo que quiera renunciar y también
ha sido muy duro con respecto al tema de
los abusos
y
encumbra a este nivel obviamente que la
feligresía
observa esto y cada día se da cuenta que
esta jerarquía lamentablemente ha caído
en lo que no tiene que caer el pecado la
feligresía que ve noticias y bueno
marcial usted conocerá por supuesto este
libro de los dos papas que relata de la
relación entre el actual papa y el papá
de mérito y también pues a la adaptación
que se hizo para la televisión y para el
cine usted cree que una de las razones
por las cuales de benedicto entrega el
cargo puede tener relación con este
conocimiento y más que inacción
imposibilidad que sentía este sacerdote
para hacer algo respecto de los abusos
de pederastas
y creo que sí yo creo que efectivamente
el papá emérito actual
llegó un momento en donde no tenía la
capacidad para poder hacer frente a lo
que se le venía y que se le venía
después de la información aparecía en el
boston globe en donde ya empiezan a
aparecer los abusos en eeuu él se da
cuenta que no puede que no puede seguir
adelante con este tema y obviamente que
da un paso al costado esto sumado al
problema del banco vaticano y a la
situación que ya al día de hoy tenemos
gente que ha sido culpada y implicarse
por lo tanto obviamente que es un
antecedente ahora al conocer este
antecedente sinceramente te digo a mí no
me sorprende porque en el año 2019 es
donde aparece la primera denuncia con
respecto al papel mérito de una de las
víctimas habitualmente las víctimas no
son escuchadas en un inicio y no se
describe y más aún cuando estás hablando
un pap a esta persona y una de una
entrevista de prensa y en esta
entrevista de prensa da a conocer cómo
fue
y como el papá mérito no hace caso
cuando le llegan efectivamente los
antecedentes la investigación comienza y
la investigación hoy día dice que no era
un caso si no habría cuatro casos que él
conocía y en lamentablemente no hizo
nada por lo tanto la lógica del dolor y
el encubrimiento sin tala en la iglesia
católica continuamos hablando de estos
estragos que causan los casos de
pederastas y de pedofilia la iglesia
dijo que indemnizará a víctimas de
abusos después de un informe que detalló
más de 200.000 casos de pederastia
dentro de la iglesia católica francesa
es suficiente esto para resarcir a las
víctimas y más tantísimos años después
mira la verdad que no es suficiente
cuando uno ha tenido la posibilidad de
conversar y estudiar estos temas se da
cuenta que el dolor de ser abusado más
aún cuando eres un menor de edad nunca
se acaba el trabajo psicológico y
psiquiátrico que se debe hacer es muy
profundo habitualmente cuando a ti
se te produce una situación de chocas
como esa cuando eres muy niño eso queda
por siempre por lo tanto todo este tipo
de situaciones en donde a ti trata una
forma de remediar el hecho concebido
obviamente que siempre queda edad y dan
menos el dinero obviamente ayuda porque
siempre hablamos de esto con dinero
digamos las cosas como son la iglesia
dice esto lo podemos reparar con dinero
pero es mucho más que dinero yo creo que
aquí hay amor hay aislamiento y una
iglesia que lamentablemente en
conciencia sabe que ha cometido este
tremendo error lo mínimo que puede hacer
es acompañar a las víctimas el tema es
que las víctimas ya no quieren ser
acompañadas por esta iglesia muchas de
ellas y se sienten absolutamente
desoladas también una de ellas que han
tocado muchas veces las puertas de la
iglesia y no fueron escuchados las
madres de estos niños no fueron
escuchados hoy día son ellos los que
golpean las puertas y muchos no son
escuchados hoy día conocemos temas en
francia- conocemos temas en alemania y
en otros países de europa como también
en américa latina como en chile yo
sinceramente creo que cada día que pasa
nos vamos a seguir encontrando con otro
tipo y vamos a seguir encontrándonos con
más casos por eso yo digo que estamos
entrando al final de la iglesia que
nosotros conocíamos y por qué digo esto
porque va a tener que tomar cartas en el
asunto mucho más duras mucho más fuertes
o mucho más
realistas de lo que hoy día se están
tomando frente a este tipo de
situaciones tan tan dolorosas